Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, add free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to the rest is history.com and join the club. That is the rest is history.com. This episode is presented by Adobe Express, the quick and easy create-anything app. What does that mean? Well, say you need to make a presentation or a video. video or a social media post or a flyer to some, certainly to me, that sounds intimidating. But Tom, with Adobe Express's intuitive features like templates, generative AI and real-time
感谢收听《这一切都是历史》。想要收听每周的独家番外、无广告节目、系列节目的抢先收听资格，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。本集由 Adobe Express 赞助播出，这是一款快捷简便、可创作任意内容的应用程序。这是什么意思呢？嗯，假设你需要做一个演示文稿、一个视频、一篇社交媒体帖子或是一份传单，对某些人来说——尤其是对我来说——这听起来让人望而生畏。但是，汤姆，借助 Adobe Express 直观的功能，例如模板、生成式人工智能和实时
collaboration, it has never been easier. Adobe Express. Try it for free. Search Adobe Express in the app store. This episode is brought to you by SAP. With investors, customers and workers demanding more from your business, it's time to try SAP. Its AI-powered capabilities can help you streamline costs, connect with new suppliers and manage payroll even when your business is being pulled in different directions, to deliver a quality product at a fair price while paying your people what they're worth too, so your business can stay unfazed. Learn more at SAP.com slash uncertainty. So Tom, we have some incredibly exciting news for our listeners in Northern Ireland and the Republic of Ireland. we? We absolutely do, Dominic, because we are going to be in Belfast, in Dublin and in Cork next year
协作，这一切从未如此简单。Adobe Express。免费试用。在应用商店中搜索 Adobe Express。本集由 SAP 赞助播出。面对投资者、客户和员工对您的业务提出越来越高的要求，是时候尝试 SAP 了。其人工智能驱动的功能可以帮助您优化成本、连接新供应商并管理薪酬，即使您的业务正被拉向不同的方向，也能以公允的价格交付优质产品，同时给予员工应得的薪酬，从而让您的业务在面对不确定性时依然从容不迫。了解更多信息，请访问 SAP.com/uncertainty。所以，汤姆，我们为北爱尔兰和爱尔兰共和国的听众带来了一个令人无比兴奋的消息。对吧？
in April, and we will be talking about the tragic story of Titanic. So we will be on stage in Belfast at the Waterfront Hall on Friday the 17th of April. We'll be in Dublin at the Convention Centre on Saturday the 18th of April and in Cork at the Opera House on Monday, the 20th of April. Tickets are on sale now for our beloved members of the Rest is History Club. So join the Rest is History Club at therestishistory.com now if you want to snap your tickets up early. And tickets will then be available to purchase for everyone else at the restishistory.com from Thursday. That's the 25th of September 2025 at 9 a.m. So for your chance to see us on stage live in Belfast,
我们当然有，多米尼克，因为我们明年将在贝尔法斯特、都柏林和科克举行现场演出，
Dublin or Cork, simply head to the rest ishistory.com to get your tickets. Ria, when she was due to bear the youngest of her children, great Zeus, travelled to Crete. There she came carrying him through the swift dark night, and taking him in her arms, she hid him in a cave hard of access, down in the secret places of the numinous earth, in the Aegean mountain with its dense woods. Then she wrapped a large stone in swaddling clothes and delivered it to her husband Cronos, the son of heaven. Seizing it with his hands, Kronos put it away in his belly, the brute,
时间是在四月份，我们将探讨泰坦尼克号的悲惨故事。因此，我们将于 4 月 17 日星期五在贝尔法斯特的水滨音乐厅（Waterfront Hall）登台演出。我们将于 4 月 18 日星期六在都柏林的会议中心（Convention Centre）演出，并于 4 月 20 日星期一在科克的歌剧院（Opera House）演出。《这一切都是历史》俱乐部尊贵的会员现在即可购买门票。因此，如果您想抢先购票，请立即登录 therestishistory.com 加入《这一切都是历史》俱乐部。随后，其他所有人也将从星期四开始在 therestishistory.com 购买门票。那是 2025 年 9 月 25 日上午 9 点。因此，想要亲临现场观看我们在贝尔法斯特、
not realizing that thereafter not a stone, but his son remained, secure and invincible, who before long was to defeat him by physical strength and drive him from his high station himself to be king among the immortals. So Tom and ladies and gentlemen, that is a very famous story. It's the story of how Zeus, who is the god worshipped by the Greeks as the king of the heavens, the lord of heaven and earth, how he managed to survive when he was a newborn baby, and to evade his father, Kronos's attempts to devour him. And Tom, that is absolutely textbook Greek mythology, isn't it? It's basically a massive family feud, horrendously violent, a lot of kind of tricks and sort of deception and tricks, exactly.
都柏林或科克演出的朋友，只需前往 therestishistory.com 购票即可。瑞亚（Rhea）在怀上她最小的孩子——伟大的宙斯时，曾前往克里特岛。在那里，她带着他穿过迅疾黑暗的夜晚，将他抱在怀里，藏进了一个隐蔽的山洞里，位于神圣大地深处的秘密之所，座落在树木茂密的爱琴山脉中。接着，她用襁褓包裹了一块大巨石，将其交给了她的丈夫、天堂之子克洛诺斯（Cronos）。克洛诺斯双手抓过巨石，将它塞进了自己的肚子里，这个野蛮的家伙，
That's the side of the Greek myths that I think when you're a, you know, when you're a child reading them, you love like Theseus and the Minotaur and the Perseus and whatnot. But quite soon you become aware of this dark undercurrent. And that's what I was associate with Greek mythology, this sort of simmering violence and sort of patricide and fratricide and so on. But I think to a degree you get that in the kind of children's histories of Greek myth as well. I mean, you have this sense that there are gods, that there are heroes, that there are all kinds of monsters, terrible things going on. And that is part of the appeal, even when you're a child, I think. And absolutely when you're an adult. And if that is your thing, then brilliant, because we've got loads of them, because we're going to be doing four episodes on the Greek myths.
却并没有意识到，此后留下的不是一块石头，而他的儿子，依然安然无恙且不可战胜，不久之后，这个儿子便会以绝对的力量击败他，将他从崇高的地位上赶下来，自己则成为永生者之王。所以，汤姆以及各位女士先生，这是一个非常著名的故事。这个故事讲述了宙斯——被希腊人奉为天堂之王、天地主宰的神明——如何在刚出生时设法存活下来，并成功躲避了他父亲克洛诺斯想要吞噬他的企图。而且，汤姆，这绝对是教科书级别的希腊神话，对吧？它基本上是一场规模宏大的家庭恩怨，极其暴力，充满了各种诡计、欺骗和权谋，确实如此。
Oh, fantastic. But, Dominic, we're not just going to be telling the stories of the Greek myths because this is a history podcast. And so, as well as telling some of the kind of the classic myths, we're going to be exploring where the myths come from, how they evolved. And I guess above all, what they might tell us about ancient Greece, this astonishing. civilization that gave birth to them. So why don't we start with the story that you have chosen to open with? Zeus, Kronos, the stone swallowing, the sort of sense of father and son locked in this sort of, you know, this sort of cosmic existential battle.
这就是希腊神话的那一面，我想当你还是个孩子阅读它们时，你会爱上诸如忒修斯与牛头怪、珀尔修斯之类的内容。但很快你就会意识到这股黑暗的暗流。而这就是我将希腊神话联系在一起的地方，这种隐约的暴力、弑父和同胞相残等等。但我想在某种程度上，你在儿童版的希腊神话历史中也能感受到这一点。我的意思是，你有这样一种感觉：这里有神明，有英雄，有各种各样的怪物，正在发生着可怕的事情。而这正是它的魅力所在，即使在你还是个孩子的时候，我想也是如此。当你成为成年人时更是如此。如果你喜欢这种风格，那太棒了，因为我们有很多这样的内容，我们将制作四集关于希腊神话的节目。
So this is, you know, it's not just textbook Greek mythology. This is the foundational Greek myth, isn't it? It is. It's doubly foundational, partly because it stands at the head of this great sweep of myths. This is about the coming of Zeus and the Olympians, but also because the poem in which it features, which is called the Theogony or the birth of the gods, is itself at the kind of the wellspring, not just of Greek poetry, but actually of European poetry. So it's fabulously ancient. It's written some three centuries before the Golden Age of Athens, so the Parthenon
哦，太棒了！但是，多米尼克，我们不仅要讲述希腊神话的故事，因为这是一个历史播客。因此，除了讲述一些经典神话之外，我们还将探讨这些神话的起源、它们的演变过程。我想最重要的是，它们可能会向我们透露关于古希腊的什么信息，这个催生了它们的令人惊叹的文明。那么，我们为什么不从你选择用来开篇的故事开始呢？宙斯、克洛诺斯、吞石事件，那种父子之间陷入这种……这种宇宙般的存在主义对决的感觉。
and Pericles and all that. Way back in the 8th century. BC, so maybe 7.30, 7.20, something like that. And its author was a man called Hesiod. And he is doing something incredibly novel because he has a brand new invention that he can use. And that invention is the alphabet, which he has got from the Phoenicians. We talked about that in the episode we did ages ago about the Phoenicians. And you can see immediately why this would be a radical innovation because previously poems had been oral. But now for the first time, because you can write them down, they can be preserved and they can be read and they can be re-read and they can pass down the generations. And that's how we get Homer's poems. I mean, they're the most
所以，你知道，这不仅是教科书级别的希腊神话。这是最基础的希腊神话，对吧？的确如此。它是双重基础性的，部分是因为它矗立在这股宏大神话潮流的最前端。这是关于宙斯和奥林匹斯众神的崛起，同时也因为承载这一情节的诗篇——被称为《神谱》（Theogony）或“诸神的诞生”——本身就处于源头地位，不仅是希腊诗歌的源头，实际上也是欧洲诗歌的源头。因此，它是极其古老的。它大约写于雅典黄金时代之前的三个世纪，所以帕台农神庙
famous of all of these. Yes. The Iliad and the Odyssey. Yes. So Homer is around the same time as Hesiod. He, of course, famously, people probably know. He's telling the story of the Trojan War, this great conflict fought between the Greeks and the Trojans, and then the return of Odysseus for 10 years back to his home in his second poem, The Odyssey. The Greeks saw these two poets, Homer and Hesiod, as the kind of the twin wellsprings of their literature. And it's unclear which of them was the first, but there were lots of Greeks back in the classical period, as there are scholars now who think that actually Hesiod was older than Homer. He essentially is where European poetry, European literature, begins.
和伯里克利以及诸如此类的事物还要早。追溯到公元前 8 世纪，大约是公元前 730 年、720 年左右。它的作者是一个名叫赫西奥德（Hesiod）的人。他正在做一件极其新颖的事情，因为他拥有一个可以使用的全新发明。而这项发明就是字母表，他是从腓尼基人那里学来的。我们在很久以前关于腓尼基人的那一集里讨论过这个。你可以立即看出为什么这是一个激进的创新，因为在此之前，诗歌一直是口头流传的。但现在，由于你可以把它们写下来，它们得以保存，得以被阅读、被反复阅读，并代代相传。这就是我们得到荷马史诗的方式。我的意思是，它们是最
And they're both writing about the gods and myths, aren't they? Yeah. But not quite in the same way. Is that right? Right. So unlike Homer, lots of debates about Homer, did he ever exist? Was he a single person? We know that Hesiod absolutely exists.
著名的。是的。《伊利亚特》和《奥德赛》。是的。所以荷马与赫西奥德生活在同一时期。当然，众所周知，他在讲述特洛伊战争的故事，这是一场在希腊人和特洛伊人之间进行的伟大冲突，然后是奥德修斯历时 10 年返回家园的第二首诗《奥德赛》。希腊人将这两位诗人荷马和赫西奥德视为他们文学的双子源泉。目前尚不清楚他们谁更早，但在古典时期有许多希腊人，就像现在的学者一样，认为赫西奥德实际上比荷马更年长。他基本上是欧洲诗歌、欧洲文学开始的地方。
And he gives us all kinds of personal details about himself in a way that Homer never does. So even if Homer is older than him, Hesiod is definitely the first writer in European history, whom we can know for sure existed and no kind of personal details about him. Presuming that the details he gives in his poems can be trusted, what we know about Hesiod is that he is the son of a Greek who had travelled from the opposite side of the Aegean to Greece proper, because Greeks had settled across the Aegean and they'd settled what's now the seaboard of Turkey, but Anatolia. So presuming that what Hesiod tells us in his poems is trustworthy, and I think there's no real reason to doubt it.
他们都在写神明和神话，对吧？是的。但方式不完全一样。是这样吗？没错。因此，与荷马不同——关于荷马有许多争论：他真的存在过吗？他是一个人吗？——我们知道赫西奥德是绝对真实存在的。
Hesiod is the son of a Greek who had traveled from the far side of the Aegean from Greece, so Anatolia, what's now Turkey, where Greeks had been settling since probably just after the time of the Trojan War. Heid's father had traveled back across the Aegean to Greece proper, and he had settled in a place called Beosha, which is just north of Athens. Hesiod and his brother Perseys had inherited farmland below a mountain called Helicon. and things had not gone well at all. So first of all, Hesiod had a massive bust up with his brother, Percy's. He accused Percy's of cheating him, of his rightful share of the inheritance that was theirs from their father.
而且他以一种荷马从未有过的方式，向我们提供了关于他自己的各种个人细节。因此，即使荷马比他年长，赫西奥德绝对是欧洲历史上第一位我们可以确定其存在并了解其个人细节的作家。假设他在诗中所给出的细节是值得信赖的，我们对赫西奥德的了解是，他是一个希腊人的儿子，这个希腊人曾从爱琴海的对岸旅行到希腊本土，因为希腊人曾在爱琴海各地定居，并在现在土耳其的海岸线即安纳托利亚定居。因此，假设赫西奥德在诗中所告诉我们的是值得信赖的，而且我认为没有真正的理由去怀疑它。
And also, the kind of the local settlement, maybe calling it a town would be to dignify it. It's a place called Ascara. Hecad says it's an absolute dump. So to quote him, it's a miserable place, bad in winter, foul in summer, good at no time. West Promitch. Yeah. It's the first kind of holiday review ever recorded in European history. However, it's not all bad news for Hesiod, because Mount Helicon, which rises up above Ascara,
赫西奥德是一个希腊人的儿子，他曾从爱琴海的远端也就是安纳托利亚（现在的土耳其）旅行到希腊。自从特洛伊战争结束后不久，希腊人就一直在那里定居。赫西奥德的父亲曾横渡爱琴海回到希腊本土，并在一个叫做维奥蒂亚（Boeotia）的地方定居，该地位于雅典以北。赫西奥德和他的兄弟珀尔修斯（Perses）继承了一座名为赫利孔山（Helicon）山脚下的农田。事情的发展一点也不顺利。首先，赫西奥德与他的兄弟珀尔修斯大吵了一架。他指责珀尔修斯欺骗了他，剥夺了他从父亲那里本应获得的合法继承份额。
this is the home of goddesses called the Muses. And they are daughters of Zeus, the king of the gods, and they are the goddesses of song. And they appear to him and take him under their wing. And they do so while Hesiod is up on the slopes of Mount Helicon, tending his sheep and his goats. and they give him a branch of springing bay, Hesiod's own words, to serve him as a staff, and they tell him to sing of the family of the blessed immortals. And this story is so important to Hesiod that he chooses to open his poem, Theogony, about the coming of the gods, with this.
还有当地的定居点——也许称它为一个城镇会显得过于高档了。那是一个叫做阿斯卡拉（Ascra）的地方。赫西奥德说那绝对是个垃圾堆。引用他的话来说，这是一个悲惨的地方，冬天糟糕，夏天恶劣，什么时候都不好。西普罗米奇。是的。这是欧洲历史上记录的第一个类似度假评价的记录。然而，对赫西奥德来说，情况并非全都是坏消息，因为耸立在阿斯卡拉上方的赫利孔山，
And so, Dominic, you may wonder why it's so important. And I think the answer is, Homer's poems are about the end of the age. of the heroes, you know, these kind of godlike figures, Achilles and Hector and Odysseus and so on. And this is the kind of the great death struggle which marks the end of this period of myth, if you want to put it like that. But Hesiod's poem is right, as we said, is right at the beginning of the age of myth. And it's describing the coming of the gods. And this is a time when there aren't really any humans at all. So the problem for Hesiod is how does he convey to people that he is licensed to do this, because actually the great hero of the
这里是被称为缪斯女神（Muses）的女神们的故居。她们是众神之王宙斯的女儿，是歌唱的女神。她们出现在他面前，并对他照顾有加。当时赫西奥德正在赫利孔山的斜坡上放羊和放山羊。她们给了他一根发芽的月桂树枝，用赫西奥德自己的话说，作为他的手杖，并告诉他要歌唱受祝福的永生者家族。这个故事对赫西奥德来说非常重要，以至于他选择用这个故事来开篇他的诗作《神谱》，讲述众神的降临。
theogony isn't someone like Achilles or Odysseus, a mortal. It's actually Zeus himself. And so this, I think, is why Hesiod's readers need to believe that what Hesiod is writing about has come from a divine inspiration, namely the muses, Zeus's own daughters. And if people do not believe that the muses have inspired Hesiod, then Hesiod is worried that they simply won't believe what he has to tell them. But to be absolutely clear, though, both Hesiod and Homer are human poets, writing human poetry. These are not by any means scriptures, kind of scriptural divine texts, are they? No. So they're not prophets. They're not priests. They're not patrolling what can or can't be said about the gods. And different cities. So Greece is a kind of patchwork
因此，多米尼克，你可能会好奇为什么这如此重要。我想答案是，荷马的诗歌是关于英雄时代终结的，你知道，这些类似神祇的人物，阿喀琉斯、赫克托耳、奥德修斯等等。这是一场伟大的生死搏斗，标志着这个神话时期的结束，如果你愿意这样称呼它的话。但是，正如我们所说，赫西奥德的诗歌恰好位于神话时代的开端。它描述了众神的降临。这是一个几乎根本没有任何人类存在的时期。因此，赫西奥德面临的问题是，他如何向人们传达他有资格这样做，因为实际上，
of cities. It's not a single country. There are different cities with their own jurisdiction dotted all over the country. They can tell different stories about the gods. There's nothing to stop them doing that. No kind of cast of priests to do that. But what Hesiod and Homer crucially provide the Greeks, all these kind of scattered regions, these scattered cities, these scattered traditions, it gives them a certain sense of structure. Doesn't that mean that it's these two poets to some degree, Hesiod and Homer, who basically, invent greatness. The idea of the Greeks as one people or one civilization is because they all look to these myths and to these stories that have spread across the Greek world. Like 19th century
《神谱》的伟大英雄并不是像阿喀琉斯或奥德修斯这样的凡人。实际上是宙斯本人。因此，我想这就是为什么赫西奥德的读者需要相信赫西奥德所写的内容来自神圣的启示，即缪斯女神——宙斯自己的女儿们。如果人们不相信缪斯女神启示了赫西奥德，那么赫西奥德就会担心他们根本不会相信他所讲述的事情。但需要完全明确的是，赫西奥德和荷马都是人类诗人，创作的是人类的诗歌。这些绝不是经文，类似于神圣的经典文本，对吧？不是的。所以他们不是先知。他们不是牧师。他们没有在监督关于神明能说或不能说的话。不同的城市——因此希腊是一个
nationalist poets inventing, you know, inventing nations. I mean, there is a sense, I think, of Greekness that pre-exists that. They speak the same language. They're essentially worshiping the same gods. But what Hesiod and Homer are doing is providing a sense of structure that will indeed then be passed down after their lifetimes to subsequent generations of Greeks and, as you say, provide them with a sense of Greekness. So to quote a very famous German scholar on this, Volta Burkart in his book Greek religion, only an authority could create order amidst such a confusion of traditions. So these are all the different traditions that the different regions and cities are saying about the gods. The authority to whom the Greeks appealed was the poetry of
由许多城市拼凑而成的国家，它不是一个单一的国家。整个国家散落着拥有各自司法管辖权的不同城市。他们可以讲述关于神明的不同故事。没有什么能阻止他们这样做。没有哪一类祭司阶层来做这件事。但是，赫西奥德和荷马至关重要地为希腊人——所有这些散落的地区、散落的城市、散落的传统——提供了一种某种程度上的结构感。难道这意味着在某种程度上正是这两位诗人，赫西奥德和荷马，基本上发明了伟大吗？希腊人作为一个民族或一种文明的理念，是因为他们都仰望这些在整个希腊世界传播的神话和故事。就像19世纪的
Hesiod and above all of Homer. The spiritual unity of the Greeks was founded and upheld by poetry a poetry which could still draw on living oral tradition. So that's descending perhaps from the age of the Trojan Wars, to produce a felicitous union of freedom and form, spontaneity and discipline. And I think this is the crucial thing about Greek myth. And it's why the Greek understanding of the dimension of the gods and the supernatural has the peculiar character that it does, namely that it's incredibly readable. The stories that you get with Greek myth,
民族主义诗人发明……发明国家一样。我的意思是，我认为确实存在一种先于此存在的希腊性。他们说同样的语言。他们本质上崇拜相同的神明。但赫西奥德和荷马所做的是提供了一种结构感，这确实将在他们有生之年之后传递给后来的希腊人代代相传，正如你所说，为他们提供了一种希腊性。因此，引用一位对此非常著名的德国学者的话：沃尔特·布尔克特（Walter Burkert）在其著作《希腊宗教》中所说：“只有权威才能在如此混乱的传统中创造秩序。”因此，这些是不同的地区和城市对众神的不同说法所产生的所有各种传统。希腊人诉诸的权威正是
are so good. It's because it is a very, very intensely literary culture, much more so than, say, you get in Babylon or Egypt. So do you think Greek myth or Greek religion is therefore more of a literary than a ritualistic thing compared with other religions of the same time period or the same kind of, you know, near-eastern religions or whatever? Is there a sense that this is a religion of the book or the story rather than of the kind of practice? Well, so the Jews that you have to pay to the gods are very important, as we'll see, the kind of the festivals and the sacrifices and so on. But the fact that the gods exist as characters in stories, I think, is overwhelmingly important and makes it very, very distinctive. And perhaps the best way to compare
赫西奥德的诗歌，最重要的是荷马的诗歌。希腊人的精神统一是由诗歌建立和维护的，这种诗歌仍然能够借鉴活生生的口头传统。因此，这或许可以追溯到特洛伊战争时代，从而产生了一种自由与形式、即兴与纪律的美妙结合。我认为这是希腊神话的关键所在。这也是为什么希腊人对神明和超自然现象维度的理解具有其独特特征的原因，也就是说它非常具有可读性。你在希腊神话中得到的故事，
the relationship of Homer to Hesiod is the I think the Lord of the Rings. And Hesiod's theogony is like the Silmarillion. So Tolkien's two great books. So the Iliad, like the Lord of the Rings, we're zooming in close to a kind of epic adventure of war and so on. But the other one, the theogony, is pulling back the camera to give us the very deep backstory. And the kind of the vitality of Tolkien's world, which has been so influential in the modern day, is due to the pairing of those. The fact that when you read Lord of the Rings, you have a sense of a massively deep backstory. And I think it's very similar for the Greeks
是如此精彩。这是因为它是一种非常、非常强烈的文学文化，比你在巴比伦或埃及看到的要强烈得多。那么，你认为希腊神话或希腊宗教与同一时期或同类近东宗教等其他宗教相比，更像是一种文学事物而不是一种仪式事物吗？是否有一种感觉，这是一门关于书本或故事的宗教，而不是关于某种实践的宗教？嗯，所以你要向神明支付的献祭非常重要，正如我们将看到的，各种节日、祭祀等等。但是神明作为故事中的角色存在这一事实，我认为是极其重要的，并且使它变得非常、非常独特。或许最好的对比方式
that when you're reading the Iliad or the Odyssey, you do have a sense that this exists in the context of the beginning of things, of the origins of the gods, of kind of stories that people can, it can be assumed that they know. But of course, there is this crucial difference with Tolkien
荷马与赫西奥德的关系就像是《指环王》。赫西奥德的《神谱》就像是《精灵宝钻》。这就是托尔金的两部伟大著作。所以《伊利亚特》就像《指环王》，我们正在近距离聚焦于一场关于战争等内容的史诗般冒险。但另一部作品《神谱》则在拉远镜头，为我们展现非常深厚的背景故事。托尔金世界的活力在现代具有如此大的影响力，正是由于这两者的结合。当你阅读《指环王》时，你会感觉到背后有一个极其深厚的背景故事。我想对于希腊人来说也是非常相似的，
that Tolkien is writing fiction. The Greeks do not think that what you're reading in Hesiod or Homer is fiction. Okay, so this is a crucial question. So when Hesiod writes to stuff, this is an act of literary craftsmanship. But does he believe it? And do the readers believe...
当你阅读《伊利亚特》或《奥德赛》时，你确实有一种感觉，即这是在万物之初、众神的起源以及人们可以理所当然认为他们了解的故事的背景下存在的。当然，这与托尔金有一个至关重要的区别：那就是托尔金在写小说。希腊人并不认为你在赫西奥德或荷马那里读到的东西是小说。好的，这是一个至关重要的问题。所以，当赫西奥德写这些东西时，这是一种文学创作的行为。但他相信它吗？读者们又相信吗……
I mean, it's the question that always puzzles you even when you're a child when you read the Greek myths. Do people who hear these stories genuinely believe that there are people up on there on Mount Olympus who are like throwing thunderbolts around, having affairs with each other, disguising themselves as showers of rain, or whatever it might be?
我的意思是，这个问题即使在你小时候读希腊神话时也会让你感到困惑。那些听到这些故事的人真的相信奥林匹斯山上住着这样一群人吗：他们四处投掷雷电，彼此有染，把自己伪装成阵雨，或者诸如此类的事情？
Do people... I mean, the Greeks are not... They're not idiots. Do they really believe this? This is a question that we will be exploring over the course of these four episodes. For most Greeks, most of the time, saying, do they believe in the gods? And you know what I'm about to see is a Christian framing of a question. Because Christianity is founded on belief.
人们……我的意思是，希腊人不是……他们不是傻瓜。他们真的相信这一点吗？这是我们在这四集节目中要探讨的问题。对于大多数希腊人在绝大多数时间里，你要问：他们信仰神明吗？你知道我接下来要说的是一种基督教式的提问方式，因为基督教是建立在信仰基础上的。
Do you believe in Christ or whatever? Yeah. I don't think the Greeks thought in those terms. And there's a brilliant framing of their relationship to the gods by a scholar of ancient Athens called Greg Anderson. Their sense of the gods is like, say, our sense of the economy or the market. Do we believe in the economy? Do we believe in the market? I mean, on one level we do, but we don't stop to think about it.
你信仰基督还是别的什么？是的。我不认为希腊人是按这种逻辑思考的。研究古雅典的学者格雷格·安德森（Greg Anderson）对他们与神明之间的关系做过一个非常精彩的框架阐述。他们对神明的感知，就像我们对经济或市场的感知一样。我们相信经济吗？我们相信市场吗？我的意思是，从某种层面来说我们是相信的，但我们不会停下来去思考它。
We just take for granted their existence, even though we can't see the market. We sense its presence everywhere. And I guess the market is a really good comparison, to say, to an Olympian god, because we know that the market can bring us good things, but we also know that it has to be appeased or it will destroy us. So what was it? The James Carville, the Rajan Cajun, said that if he could be reincarnated, he'd like to come back as the bond market, because everyone's terrified of the bond market. I think that that is the closest modern parallel to how the Greeks viewed the gods. And of course, you know, people will have different views on how the markets can be appeased. And there were similar kind of a range of opinions back in Greece about the best way of appeasing the gods.
我们只是认为它的存在是理所当然的，尽管我们看不见市场。我们到处都能感受到它的存在。我想市场真的是一个很好的比喻，用来比作奥林匹斯山的神明，因为我们知道市场能给我们带来好东西，但我们也知道必须安抚它，否则它就会毁了我们。那么是什么呢？詹姆斯·卡维尔（James Carville），那位路易斯安那州的硬汉，曾说过如果他能转世，他想变成债券市场，因为每个人都对债券市场充满恐惧。我认为这是最接近现代人如何看待希腊神明的方式。当然，你知道的，人们对如何安抚市场会有不同的看法，古希腊人对于安抚神明的最佳方式也有着各种各样的不同意见。
I mean, the question of whether you believe in the gods, I think for most Greeks never arises. Just I don't want to delay you for too long in getting on with the story. However, that raises a different question, though, which is, so people might believe in the market, but they don't tell intricate stories about the market that involve the market behaving in an anthropomorphic way. So in other words, I can completely see how a very intelligent Greek, you know, philosopher or whatever, believes that Zeus is meaningful. But does he actually think that Zeus transformed into a bull and slept with a woman or whatever, or a shower of rain or whatever it might be? Does he believe in the details of the stories? Well, you have different poets who are telling different stories about Zeus. You have different cities that tell different stories about him for reasons that will come to.
我的意思是，你是否信仰神明这个问题，我认为对大多数希腊人来说根本不会出现。我不想耽误你太长时间来继续讲这个故事。不过，这引发了另一个问题，那就是：人们可能会相信市场，但他们不会讲述关于市场的复杂故事，不会涉及市场以拟人化方式行事的行为。换句话说，我完全理解一个非常聪明的希腊人（比如哲学家之类的人）为什么会认为宙斯是有意义的。但他真的认为宙斯变成了一头公牛并与一个女人睡觉，或者是变成了一场阵雨之类的吗？他相信这些故事的细节吗？好吧，不同的诗人讲述着关于宙斯的差异故事。不同的城市出于各自的原因，也会讲述关于他的不同故事，这些我们以后都会讲到。
And sometimes these are discordant, but they're not so discordant that they unsettle the conviction of most Greeks that there is indeed a God called Zeus. And maybe some view these stories in the dimension of poetry, some view them in kind of all kinds of ways. But I think most of them do think that the stories that are told by the poets reveal the truth about the God who is father of gods and men. And that Zeus therefore does possess a kind of single coherent reality. And that's why it is possible to give a kind of biography of him. And this is a biography that depends largely upon Hesiod because it's Hesiod who gives us the details about who his parents were, how he came to overthrow his father and to become the Lord of the heavens, the father of gods and men. And some of the
有时这些故事并不一致，但它们还没有不一致到动摇大多数希腊人的信念——即确实存在一个名叫宙斯的神。也许有些人从诗歌的维度来看待这些故事，有些人则以各种各样的方式看待它们。但我认为，大多数人确实认为诗人们讲述的故事揭示了这位神明（即神明与人类之父）的真相。因此，宙斯确实拥有一种单一且连贯的现实。正因如此，为他写一本传记才成为可能。这本传记很大程度上取决于赫西奥德（Hesiod），因为正是赫西奥德为我们提供了详细信息：关于他的父母是谁，他是如何推翻父亲并成为天堂之主、神明与人类之父的，以及其中一些...
details in this story can be contested. You know, different cities give different accounts. And what I want to do in this episode is to give that kind of biography of Zeus that the Greeks would have told if you'd said, you know, sit us down and tell us who Zeus is, where he comes from, what does he do? What's he all about? Okay. So take us through Zeus's life story then, Tom. Okay. So we'll focus on the Theogony, because this is the kind of the most canonical account. And it begins not with Zeus, but with his grandmother, Gaia, who is the earth, broad-breasted earth, he said calls her, secures heat forever of all the immortals. who occupy the peak of snowy Olympus. And it's all very Greek because Gaia, the earth, gives birth to Uranus, the sky or the heaven, which the Romans, he he called Uranus. Gaia sleeps with Uranus and gives birth to 12 gods, six male, six female. These are not the Olympian gods.
这个故事中的细节是可以受到质疑的。你知道的，不同的城市给出了不同的说法。我在这集节目中想做的是，提供一种宙斯的传记，如果有人让你“坐下来告诉我们宙斯是谁，他从哪里来，他是做什么的，他到底是怎样一个神”，希腊人就会这样讲述。好的。那么，汤姆，请给我们讲讲宙斯的一生吧。好的。因此我们将重点关注《神谱》（Theogony），因为这是最经典、最权威的记载。它不是从宙斯开始的，而是从他的祖母盖亚（Gaia）开始的——赫西奥德称她为胸怀宽广的大地，她为所有占据着白雪皑皑的奥林匹斯山顶峰的不朽神灵提供了永远稳固的根基。这一切都非常具有希腊神话的色彩，因为大地盖亚生下了乌拉诺斯（Uranus），即天空或穹苍，罗马人管他叫乌拉诺斯。盖亚与乌拉诺斯交合，生下了十二位神明，六男六女。这些还不是奥林匹斯山的神明。
These are gods called Titans. And the youngest of these, Hesia tells us, was Kronos, the crooked schemer, most fearsome of children. And Kronos loathed his lusty father. So the lusty father is Aranos. And lusty is the word, because Aranus just can't help himself. He just keeps getting poor Gaia pregnant. And she just gives birth to more and more children. So some of these are Cyclops, the giants with one eye, like Polyphemus, who Odysseus will meet in due course.
这些被称为泰坦神（Titans）。赫西奥德告诉我们，他们之中最小的是克洛诺斯（Kronos），这个诡计多端、最令人畏惧的孩子。克洛诺斯痛恨他那好色的父亲。所以这个好色的父亲就是乌拉诺斯。“好色”这个词用得很贴切，因为乌拉诺斯就是控制不住自己。他不停地让可怜的盖亚怀孕。而盖亚则不断地生下一个又一个孩子。其中一些是独眼巨人（Cyclops），也就是像波吕斐摩斯（Polyphemus）那样只有一个眼睛的巨人，奥德修斯在适当的时候会遇到他。
These are people who can forge thunderbolts, which are the kind of the nuclear missiles of Greek mythology, absolutely devastating and lethal. Gaia also gives birth to a succession of monsters, which have 100 arms and 50 heads. And their own father, Hesiod tells us, so that's Oranos, loath them from the beginning. As soon as each of them was born, he hid them all away in a cavern of Gaia and would not let them into the light. And he took pleasure in the wicked work, did Oranos, while the huge Gaia was tired. pressed inside and groaned. So, I mean, not pleasant. I mean, I guess imagine if you've given birth having the baby shoved back inside you and then a whole load more of cyclops and monsters with 100 arms. I mean, that's not nice at all. And so Gaia isn't keen on what's
这些人能够锻造雷电，雷电就像是希腊神话中的核导弹，具有绝对的毁灭性和致命性。盖亚还生下了一连串的怪物，它们有一百只手臂和五十个头。赫西奥德告诉我们，它们的亲生父亲乌拉诺斯从一开始就厌恶它们。它们一出生，乌拉诺斯就把它们全部藏在盖亚的洞穴深处，不让它们见光。乌拉诺斯以这种邪恶的勾当为乐，而巨大的盖亚则被压在里面痛苦呻吟。所以，我的意思是，这可真不好受。我想象一下，如果你生了孩子，结果婴儿又被塞回你的肚子里，接着又生出一大堆独眼巨人和长着一百只手臂的怪物。我的意思是，这真的一点也不好玩。所以盖亚对正在发生的事情...
happening. And she manufactures this stone called adamant and then she makes a sickle out of it. And she gives it to her son, Kronos. And Kronos takes the sickle and slick. He slices off uranus's testicles. Right, castrates his own father, unmanes his own father. Wow. Yes. So uranos is actually the first unit. In all history. In all history. And Cronos picks up the severed testicles and he flings them away and as they fly, blood and semen drips out of them and they land and give birth to the race of the giants. And then the severed testicles, they land in the sea, traditionally very near Cyprus, it was said. And this foam, Afros in Greek, is churned up. And from the foam emerges the goddess Aphrodite. So hence her name. And Hesiod tells us that
感到很不满，于是她制造了一种叫做坚金（adamant）的石头，并用它做了一把镰刀。她把它交给了她的儿子克洛诺斯。克洛诺斯拿着镰刀，手起刀落。他切掉了乌拉诺斯的睾丸。没错，阉割了自己的父亲，让他失去了男人的尊严。哇。是的。所以乌拉诺斯实际上是历史上第一个太监。在整个历史上。克洛诺斯捡起被割下的睾丸，把它们扔了出去。在它们飞翔的时候，鲜血和精液从上面滴落下来，它们落到地上，孕育出了巨人族。然后，被割下的睾丸落入海中，传统上据说非常靠近塞浦路斯。希腊语中的泡沫“阿夫洛斯”（Afros）被翻腾起来。从泡沫中诞生了女神阿芙罗狄蒂（Aphrodite）。这就是她名字的由来。赫西奥德告诉我们...
her dimension is the whisperings of girls, smiles, deceptions, sweet pleasure, intimacy, and tenderness. Yeah. So that's one story about the birth of Aphrodite. There is another tradition that she's the daughter of Zeus. So that's an example of how kind of various these traditions are, but this is the kind of the most famous account. It's the one that you get in Botticelli's famous painting of Venus, aka Aphrodite, rising from the waves. So Kronos is the big man now. Kronos is top dog. He's king of the gods. In good Greek fashion, he marries his own sister, doesn't he, Ria? Yeah. And he also shut up the cyclops. He's got rid of the Cyclopsies. They're in Tartarus. What's Tartarus kind of hell? It's a kind of shadowy dimension beneath
她的领域是少女的耳语、微笑、欺骗、甜蜜的快乐、亲密和温柔。是的。所以这是关于阿芙罗狄蒂诞生的一个故事。还有另一个传统认为她是宙斯的女儿。这就是这些传统有多么多样化的一个例子，但这是最著名的说法。你在波提切利（Botticelli）的名画中看到的维纳斯（又名阿芙罗狄蒂）从波涛中升起，就是这个版本。所以克洛诺斯现在是老大。克洛诺斯是顶尖人物。他是众神之王。按照正统的希腊风俗，他娶了自己的亲妹妹瑞亚（Rhea），对吧？是的。他还把独眼巨人关了起来。他除掉了独眼巨人。他们被关在塔耳塔罗斯（Tartarus）里。塔耳塔罗斯是什么？类似于地狱。它是...
the earth. Right. So he's married Rhea. They in turn have six children. And these are the Olympians. So you have three girls, Hestia, Demeter, and Hera. And you have three boys, Hades, Poseidon, and Seuss. And Kronos, he has been alerted to a prophecy. So again, to quote Hesiod, he'd learned from Gaia and Stari Uranos that he was fated to be overthrown by his own child, just as Kronos had overthrown Aranos. And so he tries to escape his doom by devouring each one of his children as they're born, kind of gulped them down. And the last born of these six children is Zeus. And this is what prompts Rea to pull her stone in swaddling clothes trick. So it wraps up a stone in swaddling clothes, gives it to Pronos and he just gulps it down.
地球下方一个阴暗的维度。没错。所以他娶了瑞亚。他们又生了六个孩子。这些就是奥林匹斯神。所以你有三个女儿：赫斯提亚（Hestia）、德墨忒尔（Demeter）和赫拉（Hera）。你还有三个儿子：哈迪斯（Hades）、波塞顿（Poseidon）和宙斯（Zeus）。克洛诺斯收到了一条预言的警告。因此，再次引用赫西奥德的话，他从盖亚和星光灿烂的乌拉诺斯那里得知，他注定会被自己的亲生子嗣推翻，正如克洛诺斯曾经推翻乌拉诺斯那样。因此，他试图通过吞下自己的每一个孩子来逃避厄运，像这样把他们一口吞下去。这六个孩子中最后一个出生的是宙斯。这就促使瑞亚施展了“用襁褓包裹石头”的把戏。她用襁褓包裹了一块石头，交给了克洛诺斯，而他二话不说就把它吞了下去。
Rhea then takes Zeus away and hides him. And there are all kinds of traditions about where Zeus is hidden. The most famous seem to have arisen in Crete. That seems to be the kind of general consensus is that Zeus was hidden on Crete. Hesiod doesn't go into this, but there are all these kind of stories about how Zeus gets hidden in a cave under a mountain, and there's a band of young warriors who dance around him,
瑞亚随后带走并藏起了宙斯。关于宙斯被藏在哪里，有各种各样的传说。最著名的似乎起源于克里特岛。这似乎是普遍共识，即宙斯被藏在克里特岛上。赫西奥德没有详细说明这一点，但有各种各样关于宙斯如何被藏在山下一个山洞里的故事，那里有一群年轻的勇士围着他跳舞，
beating their spears on the shields to prevent the baby's uses, crying from being heard. And there's a supernatural goat, which is a Malthier whose teats give him a mixture of milk and honey. So that's very nice for the baby's use. And so he grows up a strapping young lad.
用长矛敲击盾牌，以防止小宙斯的哭声被听到。还有一只超自然的母山羊，名叫阿玛尔忒亚（Amalthea），它的奶头为他提供奶和蜜的混合物。这对小宙斯来说真是太好了。于是他成长为一个强壮的年轻小伙子。
Then he goes to man. hood and he is ready to go on the attack against Kronos. It's not exactly clear how he does this. Presumably he gives Kronos an emetic, but Kronos vomits up. The stone vomits up. Zeus's five siblings. Zeus takes the stone, places it in Delphi, where the great oracle will be, to be a thing of wonder for mortal men.
然后他长大成人，准备向克洛诺斯发起攻击。目前还不清楚他是怎么做到这一点的。大概是他给克洛诺斯下了催吐剂，结果克洛诺斯吐出了那块石头，也吐出了宙斯的五个兄弟姐妹。宙斯拿起这块石头，把它放在德尔斐（Delphi），也就是伟大的神谕所在地，让它成为凡人眼中的奇观。
And with his siblings, he then launches a war against Kronos and his allies, the Titans. And the first thing that Zeus does after getting his siblings up out of Kronos's stomach is to go to Tartarus and open up the gates and to get out the Cyclops. And I mentioned how they're absolutely whiz at constructing weapons of mass destruction, aka the Thunderbolts. And this is what they do. They make Thunderbolts for Zeus. And there's this 10-year war that the Olympians fight against the Titans. And it's the Thunderbolts that prove decisive. Because when Zeus gets it's them, he can incinerate his enemies, and Kronos and the Titans are raised low, and it is now they who get imprisoned in Tartarus.
他和兄弟姐妹们一起对克洛诺斯和他的盟友泰坦神发动了战争。宙斯把兄弟姐妹们从克洛诺斯的胃里救出来后，做的第一件事就是去塔耳塔罗斯打开大门，把独眼巨人放出来。我提到过他们绝对是制造大规模杀伤性武器（也就是雷霆）的天才。这就是他们所做的。他们为宙斯制造了雷霆。奥林匹斯神与泰坦神进行了这场历时十年的战争。事实证明，雷霆起到了决定性作用。因为当宙斯拿到它们时，他可以把敌人烧成灰烬，克洛诺斯和泰坦神被打倒在地，现在轮到他们被关进塔耳塔罗斯了。
And again, to quote Hesiod, there they languish in misty gloom, condemned by Zeus, the cold gatherer in a place of decay at the end of the vast earth, and the Titans forge great bronze doors that lock them in, the 100-armed monsters, remember them, they're still on the scene. They are appointed by Zeus to serve as jailers, to stand-out. outside the great bronze gates. And as Hesiod puts it, the titans have no way out. They are securely locked up. Wow.
再次引用赫西奥德的话，他们在那里于朦胧的阴暗中饱受煎熬，被冷酷的宙斯判处在广袤大地的尽头一个腐朽的地方受罚，泰坦神们锻造了巨大的青铜门将他们锁在里面，那些长着一百只手臂的怪物——还记得他们吗？他们还在现场。他们被宙斯委任为狱卒，站在巨大青铜门的外侧。正如赫西奥德所说，泰坦神们无路可逃。他们被牢牢锁在里面。哇。
There's stuff like this in Norse mythology, isn't there? Sort of different generations of gods fighting each other. And this idea of generational conflict is at the heart of so many of the kind of world's great mythologies. Anyway, we can come on to dissecting the story and exploring where it comes from in the second half. Now, Zeus is top dog. He is.
北欧神话里也有类似的东西，对吧？某种不同代际的神明互相战斗。这种代际冲突的概念是许多世界伟大神话的核心。无论如何，我们可以在下半场继续剖析这个故事并探索它的起源。现在，宙斯是老大。他是。
He and his brothers rule the cosmos. And they divide it up between them. don't they? And they do that by a lot. They do. And the result of this is told us not by Hesia, but by Homer. Poseidon won the Grey Sea. He becomes the god of the oceans. Hades, the murky darkness, he becomes the god of the dead. Zeus, the broad heavens. And Zeus then carries on the family tradition by marrying his sister, Heera,
他和他的兄弟们统治着宇宙。他们把宇宙在彼此之间瓜分了，对吧？他们通过抽签来做到这一点。确实如此。而关于这一结果，告诉我们的不是赫西奥德，而是荷马。波塞顿赢得了苍茫的大海，他成为了海洋之神。哈迪斯赢得了阴暗的冥界，他成为了死神。宙斯赢得了广阔的天空。然后宙斯继承了家族传统，娶了他的妹妹赫拉，
and they rule as king and queen on Mount Olympus. And as you say, there is now no defying Zeus because he's stronger than all the other gods combined. The way that the Greeks illustrates Zeus, both of them convey the sense of his power, his awesome might. So the oldest representations of Zeus show him striding forwards, front foot forward,
他们作为国王和王后统治着奥林匹斯山。正如你所说，现在没有人敢违抗宙斯，因为他比其他所有神明的总和还要强大。希腊人描绘宙斯的方式，都传达出他那种无可匹敌的力量和令人敬畏的威严。因此，最早对宙斯的艺术表现显示他大步向前，前脚迈出，
holding a thunderbolt in his upraised arm. And the other representation of him, he's sat enthroned with a scepter and an eagle by his side. But isn't the implication of these stories? So you've got Kronos
高举的手臂中握着一道闪电。而对他的另一种表现形式是，他坐在王座上，手持权杖，身旁陪伴着一只老鹰。但是，这些故事难道没有隐含着这样的意味吗？你看，克洛诺斯
overthrew his own father. Then Zeus overthrew Kronos. Yeah. Is not the expectation. It's like one of those sort of recurring patterns that you have to do as a child. It's not the expectation that one of Zeus's children will overthrow him in turn. And that's how the cycle, that is how the world turns. Absolutely.
推翻了自己的父亲。然后宙斯推翻了克洛诺斯。是的。难道人们不会预料到——这就像那种你作为孩子时必须经历的某种循环往复的模式——难道不会预料到宙斯的某个孩子反过来也会推翻他吗？而这就是循环，这就是世界运转的方式。绝对是这样的。
There is clearly a sense, I guess, among the poets that this would, if you like, be poetic justice for Zeus. But Zeus's power is such that he can checkmate the temptation poets might have to kind of pull that trick on him. So in Hesiod, Hesiod does allude very directly to such a tradition, and he says that the son of a goddess called METIS, goddess of kind of intelligence of wisdom, that any child born to Metus is destined to overthrow his father. And of course, this is potentially an absolutely mortal danger to Zeus, because he's been sleeping with her. Metus gets pregnant, and Zeus is thrown into a massive panic. And so according to a late tradition, what he does is to say, oh, darling, would you show me how proficient you are at changing your form? Perhaps you would like to change into a fly. And so Meters does change into a fly and Zeus reaches out, grabs the fly and swallows her.
显然，诗人们心中有一种感觉，如果你愿意这么说的话，这对比宙斯来说将是“诗意的正义”。但宙斯的力量如此强大，以至于他能够抵消诗人们可能想要对她玩这种把戏的诱惑。因此，在赫西奥德的作品中，赫西奥德非常直接地暗示了这样一个传统：他说，一个名叫墨提斯（Metis，象征智慧与谋略的女神）的女神所生的儿子，注定要推翻他的父亲。当然，这可能对宙斯构成绝对的致命威胁，因为他一直在和她睡觉。墨提斯怀孕了，宙斯陷入了极度的恐慌。因此，根据一个后来的传说，他所做的是说：“哦，亲爱的，你能向我展示一下你变幻形态的本领有多高超吗？也许你想变成一只苍蝇。”于是墨提斯真的变成了一只苍蝇，宙斯伸出手，抓住了这只苍蝇并把它吞了下去。
And this proves a very smart move because not only has he got rid of Metus and the baby in Metus's belly, but Metus, as we said, is the goddess of wisdom. And so her wisdom is now Zeus's. And Hesiod spells out what this means for Zeus. Now that Metus was in his belly, the goddess could advise him of what was good and bad. And also he doesn't lose his child because this child turns out to be the goddess who will give her name to Athens, Athena. And she famously bursts out, fully formed, clad in armor from Zeus's fore. forehead. He has a splitting headache. It gets split open with an axe and out Athena leaps. And she's a girl, not a boy, so she won't be able to inherit the throne of the heavens.
事实证明，这是一个非常明智的举动，因为他不仅摆脱了墨提斯以及墨提斯肚子里的孩子，而且正如我们所说，墨提斯是智慧女神。因此，她的智慧现在归宙斯所有了。赫西奥德详细阐述了这对宙斯意味着什么。既然墨提斯留在了他的腹中，这位女神就能为他指点善恶。而且他也没有失去自己的孩子，因为这个孩子后来成了赐予雅典这座城市名字的女神——雅典娜。她最著名的出场方式是全副武装、身穿铠甲，从宙斯的额头中破额而出。他当时头痛欲裂，头部被斧头劈开，雅典娜便从里面跳了出来。她是个女孩，不是男孩，所以她将无法继承天堂的王座。
But she's, you know, one of the most distinctive and potent of all the Olympians. And it is said Zeus's favorite child. But I guess there's a difference, isn't it, between Zeus and Kronos? Not just that Zeus is more powerful and he's never going to be overthrown. Zeus is terrifying and formidable and absolutely, you know, sort of awe-inspiring. But also he is a benevolent father, is that right? And he's sort of a, he's the incarnation of justice and of wisdom and all these kinds of things. Well, yes. So he's got, he's now got Metus in his stomach. Right. And so Meters can advise him. So yes. And both Hesia and Homer do insist on this, that when, when Zeus kind of determines the affairs of gods and men, he's doing so not as a tyrant, not like
但你知道，她是所有奥林匹斯神中最独特、最有权势的神之一。据说她也是宙斯最喜欢的孩子。不过我想宙斯和克洛诺斯之间还是有区别的吧？不仅仅是宙斯更强大，而且他永远不会被推翻。宙斯是可怕的、威严的，绝对是那种让人敬畏的存在。但同时他也是一位慈父，对吗？他某种程度上是正义、智慧以及诸如此类品质的化身。嗯，是的。所以他现在把墨提斯吞进了肚子。对的。因此墨提斯可以给他出谋划策。所以是的。无论是赫西奥德还是荷马都坚持这一点：当宙斯裁决神明和人类的事务时，他并不是以暴君的身份，不像
Kronos. But as a father, he's father's use. He oversees justice. He organizes the cosmos wisely. This is kind of fundamental to the way that both these great poets, Hesiod and Homer, portrays use. And there's a sense, perhaps a kind of echo there of the biblical God. So Hesiod, when he opens another his poems, not the Theogony, another one, he does say with a prayer that lots of scholars have said seems to echo the Psalms that you get in the Bible. So to quote it, this is, he should talking about Zeus, easily he makes the crooked straight and withers the proud, Zeus who thunders on high, who dwells in the highest mansions. Oh, hearken as thou seest and hearest and make judgments straight with righteousness. I mean, that wouldn't be out of place. No, not at all.
克洛诺斯那样。而是像一位父亲，他是父神宙斯。他监督正义。他明智地组织宇宙。这是这两位伟大诗人——赫西奥德和荷马——塑造宙斯形象的根本所在。而且这里面似乎带有一种圣经上帝的某种回响。所以赫西奥德在开启他的另一首长诗（不是《神谱》，而是另一首）时，曾向上帝祈祷，许多学者说这似乎在呼应《圣经》中的诗篇。引用他的话，这是赫西奥德在谈论宙斯：他轻易地将弯曲的抚平，让傲慢者枯萎，高居云端、住在至高宫殿的雷霆宙斯。噢，求你聆听，正如你所见所闻，并以公义作出正直的判决。我的意思是，这放在
In a kind of song of praise to the biblical God. And likewise, in Homer, there's a famous scene when Achilles and Hector are fighting at the end of the Iliad. And Zeus gets these golden scales and holds them up and he weighs the fate of the two heroes in the balance and hector's scale dips so it is ordained that he must die and zeus mourns this but he of course acts in accordance with what is right because it is his duty to uphold that he can do this because he only has to make a decision and immediately it is enacted and there's another very famous passage in the iliad where homer describes this so to quote it zeus the son of cronos bowed his craggy dark brows and the deathless locks came pouring down from the thunderhead of the great immortal king, and giant shockwaves spread through
赞美圣经上帝的赞美诗里一点也不违和。不，一点也不。同样，在荷马史诗中有一个著名的场景：阿喀琉斯和赫克托耳在《伊利亚特》结尾处激战，宙斯拿起了金色的天平高高举起，在天平上权衡这两位英雄的命运，结果赫克托耳的那端下沉了，于是冥冥中注定他必须死。宙斯为此感到悲伤，但他当然还是依照正义行事，因为维护正义是他的职责。他能做到这一点，是因为他只需做一个决定，事情就会立刻付诸实施。《伊利亚特》中还有另一个非常著名的片段，荷马是这样描述的——引用他的话说：克洛诺斯的儿子宙斯低下他那块状阴暗的眉头，不朽的发卷从这位伟大不朽之王的雷云头顶倾泻而下，
all Olympus. And these were lines that were said to have inspired the most famous of all Greek sculptors, Fidias, who was working in the 5th century BC, who made the great sculpture of Athena that stood in the Parthenon, but he also made one of the seven wonders of the ancient world, the statue of Zeus at Olympia. That passage from Homer is what inspired him when he came to try and portray. the majesty and splendor of Zeus. But more Zeus, skeptical listeners, may well object to this point.
巨大的冲击波传遍了整个奥林匹斯山。据说这些诗句启发了公元前5世纪最著名的古希腊雕塑家菲狄亚斯。他创作了矗立在帕特农神庙中的雅典娜巨像，不过他也创作了古代世界七大奇迹之一——奥林匹ีย斯的宙斯神像。荷马的那段诗句就是他试图刻画宙斯的威严与壮丽时的灵感来源。但是，对宙斯持怀疑态度的听众很可能会对此提出异议。
And so point out, you've already referred to his philandering. And actually by, you know, it's a stupid comparison, but I'll make it anyway. By today's standards, you know,
他们会指出，你刚才已经提到了他的风流韵事。实际上，你知道，这是一个愚蠢的比喻，但我还是要打个比方。按照今天的标准，你知道，
he's positively kind of Weinsteinian in his attitude towards younger women. He's a massive predator. Yes. And he's a rapist, actually, isn't he? Yes. So there's a huge,
他在对待年轻女性的态度上，简直就像温斯坦那样，是个不折不扣的大掠夺者。是的。而且实际上他是个强奸犯，对吧？是的。所以有一个庞大的，
list. Yes. I mean, to give us a sense to him, his own sister, Demeter, he sleeps with. It gives birth to Persephone. Right. His aunt, I mean, I think it's a, that's. Yeah. So, yeah, so his aunt is, is the goddess of memory. She gives birth to the muses who appear to Hesiod on Mount Helicon. He sleeps with his own cousin, Leto, and the Leto in due cause gives birth to twins, Apollo and Artemis, who again will join the ranks of the gods on Olympus, and he sleeps with his second cousin, Maya, and Maya's son is Hermes, the messenger of the gods, again, one of the Olympians. So lots of kind of me-toeing with other gods and with his own family. Yeah. But that's not even to mention all the many mortal women he gets pregnant. And so, understandably, poor Hera, I mean, she's defined by her marriage disuse, of course,
名单。是的。为了让我们对他的行为有个概念，他甚至和自己的亲妹妹德墨忒尔同床共枕。生下了珀耳塞福涅。没错。他的姑姑——我的意思是，我认为这是一件，对。所以，是的，所以他的姑姑就是记忆女神。她生下了缪斯女神，这些缪斯在赫利孔山上向赫西奥德显现。他与自己的亲表妹勒托同床，勒托随后生下了双胞胎阿波罗和阿尔忒密斯，他们又将加入奥林匹斯诸神的行列；他还与自己的第二个表妹玛雅同床，玛雅的儿子就是众神的信使赫尔墨斯，他同样也是奥林匹斯神之一。所以，与其他神明以及他自己的家族之间有很多这种“Me too”式的行为。是的。但这甚至还没算上他让无数凡间女性怀孕的事。因此，可以理解的是，可怜的赫拉——我的意思是，她当然是由她与宙斯的婚姻来定义的，
she's the queen of the heavens, but she's also defined by her entirely understandable jealousy and resentment of the fact that Zeus is endlessly going off and sleeping with other women and her persecution of all these women who she sees as her rivals. And so you're absolutely right to fix on this as an issue, the God of the Bible. He's not behaving like this. No, definitely not. So what's going on with Zeus? How can Zeus be both glorious and great and supreme and just and all of that, and an adulterer and a rapist. Well, I think we should address that question
她是天后，但她也同样被一种完全可以理解的嫉妒心和怨恨所定义，因为宙斯没完没了地出去和其他女人睡觉，而她则迫害所有被她视为情敌的女性。所以你抓住这一点作为问题是绝对正确的：圣经中的上帝可不是这样行事的。不，绝对没有。那么宙斯到底是怎么回事？为什么宙斯既能光荣、伟大、至高无上、公正无私，同时又是一个通奸者和强奸者？好吧，我认为我们应该在下半场探讨这个问题。
in the second half of this podcast. And not only that, but let's have a little look at the deep history of Zeus and his cult and where they came from and what they tell us about the world of the ancient Greeks. So we'll see you then. This episode is brought to you by the London Review of Books. Now, Tom, as you well know,
在这期播客的后半部分。不仅如此，让我们顺便了解一下宙斯及其崇拜的悠久历史，看看它们是从哪里来的，以及它们向我们揭示了古希腊人怎样的世界。我们一会儿见。本期节目由《伦敦书评》赞助播出。那么，汤姆，正如你所知，
some sources suggest that Helen of Troy never actually set foot in Troy Helen's role in myth is constantly shifting. Sometimes she's a goddess, sometimes she's a scapegoat, sometimes she's a phantom. Now on this subject, the LRB, the London Review of Books, has just depaywalled two absolutely superb essays. So one of them is by Marina Warner, and that's one about Helen of Troy's shape-shifting legend. And the other is Mary Beard, and she is writing about how classical stories have been used to frame and to reshaping. strain female power.
一些资料表明，特洛伊的海伦实际上从未踏足过特洛伊。海伦在神话中的角色一直在不断变化。有时她是女神，有时她是替罪羊，有时她是一个幻影。关于这个主题，《伦敦书评》（LRB）刚刚免费开放了两篇极其精彩的文章。其中一篇由玛丽娜·华纳撰写，讲述的是特洛伊海伦那千变万化的传说。另一篇由玛丽·比尔德撰写，她探讨了古典故事是如何被用来构建和限制女性力量的。
Together they show that myth is the flickering shadow of history. It's a tool reshaped, redacted and rewritten to suit whoever holds the pen. That's what the London Review of Books does best. Serious history, literary depth. And Tom, you know what? It has the nerve to leave the edges frayed. So read both pieces now at the LRB website. and if you enjoy them, then you can subscribe to access their full archive.
它们共同表明，神话是历史忽隐忽现的影子。它是一种被重塑、被删改、被重写的工具，以迎合任何手握笔杆的人。《伦敦书评》最擅长的就是这一点：严肃的历史，文学的深度。而且汤姆，你知道吗？它甚至有胆量保留那些毛边。现在就去LRB网站阅读这两篇文章吧，如果你喜欢它们，还可以订阅以访问他们的全部档案。
LRB are offering six months for just £12. It's unbelievable value, plus even better value, a free tote bag. Visit lrb.m.m.m. slash history. That is lrb.m.m.m.m. slash history. This episode is brought to you by Uber. Now, do you know that feeling when someone shows up for you when you need it most? We all need that sometimes. And Uber knows it. Uber isn't just a ride or a meal delivered. It's showing up no matter what. Like for your long distance friends, bringing soup when they're sick, sending flowers when they're down.
LRB目前正推出六个月仅需12英镑的优惠。这简直是难以置信的超值优惠，而且还有更好的福利——免费送一个托特包。请访问 lrb.m.m.m/history。也就是 lrb.m.m.m.m/history。本期节目由 Uber 赞助播出。那么，你是否经历过那种在你最需要的时候有人挺身而出的时刻？我们有时都需要这样的支持。Uber 深知这一点。Uber 不仅仅是一次行程或一顿外卖。它意味着无论如何都会鼎力相助。就像对于你的异地朋友，在他们生病时送去热汤，在他们情绪低落时送去鲜花。
When it really matters, whatever it is, you show up. Where there's a will, we're on our way. Uber on our way. Download the app today. During the Volvo Fall Experience event, discover exceptional offers and thoughtful design that leaves plenty of room for autumn adventures. And see for yourself how Volvo's legendary safety brings peace of mind to every crisp morning commute. This September, leased a 2026 XE90 plug-in hybrid from $599 biweekly at 3.99% during the Volvo fall experience event. Conditions apply, visit your local Volvo retailer or go to explorevolvo.com. The 12 gods of Olympus agreed to appear as entirely human.
当真正重要的时候，无论是什么事情，你都会挺身而出。有志者，事竟成，我们在路上了。Uber 在路上。今天就下载应用程序吧。在沃尔沃秋季体验活动期间，探索非凡的优惠和周到的设计，为您的秋季探险留出充足的空间。亲自体验沃尔沃传奇般的安全性能如何为每一个清爽的早晨通勤带来内心的平静。今年九月，在沃尔沃秋季体验活动期间，租赁 2026 款 XC90 插电式混合动力车，每两周只需 599 美元起，利率为 3.99%。需遵守相关条款，请访问当地沃尔沃经销商或访问 explorevolvo.com。奥林匹斯的12位神明一致同意以完全人类的形象出现。
It was the first time a group of divinities had renounced abstraction and animal heads. No more the unrepresentable behind the flower or the swastika. No more the monstrous creature, the stone fallen from heaven, the whirlpool. Now, the gods took on a cool, polished skin or an unreal warmth and a body where you could see the ripple of muscles, the long veins. The change brought with it a new exhilaration and a new terror. So that was Roberto Calasso's The Marriage of Cadmus and Harmony. I'm reading it as though I know what it's about. I've actually never read it, Tom. It's a fantastically odd book, brilliant book, brilliantly original. It gives you the Greek myths, but in a way that you've never
这是神灵群体第一次放弃抽象概念和动物头像。不再有花朵或万字饰背后那个无法描绘的存在。不再有可怕的怪物、从天而降的石头、汹涌的漩涡。现在，众神披上了凉爽、抛光的皮肤或一种不真实的热度，拥有了可以看到肌肉线条和纤细血管的躯体。这种转变带来了一种新的兴奋感，也带来了一种新的恐惧。以上节选自罗伯托·卡拉索的《卡德摩斯与哈耳摩尼亚的婚礼》。我读得好像我很懂这本书似的。汤姆，其实我从来没读过它。这是一本极其怪异的书，一本才华横溢的书，极其独创。它向你讲述了希腊神话，但方式是你从未
read them before. And again and again, it kind of brings you up short against what is distinctive and strange about Greek myth. And I think that's a kind of perfect example because we read about the Greek gods as children. It can be easy to forget how strange they are when compared to the gods of other cultures, you know, Egyptian or Babylonian or Indian gods. And the way in which the strangeness of the Greek gods is precisely that they are kind of. of so human or perhaps you could say kind of hyperhuman. And they are very, very strange when you compare them to the gods of other pantheons. You know, I mean, that's what Colasse is referring to, the animal heads and immediately think of the Egyptian gods. And I guess that in turn, that's one of
读到过的。它一次又一次地让你停下来，去思考希腊神话中那些独特而奇异的地方。我认为这是一个完美的例子，因为我们从小就读希腊神话。与其它文化的神明（比如埃及、巴比伦或印度的神明）相比，人们很容易忘记希腊神明是多么奇特。希腊神明的奇异之处，恰恰在于它们是如此之“人”，或者你也可以说它们具有某种“超级人性”。当你把它们与其他神话体系的神明进行比较时，它们真的是非常、非常奇特。你知道我的意思，卡拉索所指的就是动物头像，而我们马上就会想到埃及神明。我想反过来，这也是为什么
the reasons why children find the stories of the Greek gods so appealing. And it's why they endure as literary characters. They're kind of so human that they become superhuman. You know, They play the role of superheroes. Well, I was about to say superheroes. It might sound as a very trivial comparison. But the point about, you know, comic book superheroes is that they're both far greater than us and they are very human. And the sort of petty, trivial, slightly demeaning qualities with which the gods are imbued, that's what makes them appealing to a child reader, right? They're jealous and they're venal and they lie and cheat and all of those kinds of things.
孩子们觉得希腊神话故事如此吸引人的原因之一。这也是为什么它们能够作为文学角色流传至今。它们如此贴近人性，以至于变成了超人。你知道的，它们扮演着超级英雄的角色。好吧，我正想说超级英雄。这听起来可能是一个非常琐碎的类比。但关于漫画书超级英雄的关键点在于，他们既比我们伟大得多，又非常有人情味。而正是赋予诸神的那些小气、琐碎、略带贬损的特质，才让他们对小读者产生了吸引力，对吧？他们会嫉妒，他们唯利是图，他们撒谎作弊，诸如此类。
Which is to say that in the portrayal of the Greek gods, there are all kinds of contradictions and complexities and ambivalences. But the achievement of the poets, Eziat, Homer, and then the other great poets that will be looking out over the course of this series, they kind of synthesize them and they do it to such potent effect that Zeus and the other Olympians, you know, as we keep saying, continue to fascinate to this day, far more than any other group of gods. I would say, from any comparable pantheon. Yeah, definitely. But Dominic, you were asking before the break, where do these contradictions come from, say, in the character of Zeus, and how are they reconciled? He said in the Theogony explains the origins of Zeus
也就是说，在对希腊神的塑造中，存在着各种各样的矛盾、复杂性和矛盾心理。但几位诗人的成就——赫西奥德、荷马，以及我们在本系列节目中将要探讨的其他伟大的诗人们——他们将这些元素进行了综合，并产生了如此强大的效果，正如我们一直所说的那样，宙斯和其他奥林匹斯神至今仍然令人着迷，远超任何其他神群。我认为，比起任何可比的神话体系都是如此。是的，绝对如此。但是，多米尼克，你在中场休息前曾问过，这些矛盾是从哪里来的？比如在宙斯的性格中，它们又是如何调和的？赫西奥德在《神谱》中解释了宙斯的起源，
in terms of his descent from the earth and from the heavens. But scholars, since the end of the 18th century, have known better, specifically since 1786, because that was the year when a British scholar in Calcutta, a guy called Sir William Jones, gave a lecture in Calcutta. And in it, he demonstrated the Greek, Latin, Sanskrit, the ancient language of India. These languages all shared a common linguistic route. And you can see this very clearly when you look at the name of Zeus.
认为他是从大地和天空繁衍而来的。但自18世纪末以来，学者们有了更好的见解，特别是自1786年以来，因为那一年，加尔各答的一位英国学者，一个名叫威廉·琼斯爵士的人，在加尔各答发表了一场演讲。在演讲中，他证明了希腊语、拉丁语、梵语（印度的古老语言）这几种语言都有一个共同的语言根源。当你看到宙斯的名字时，这一点就能看得非常清楚。
So the full name of Zeus is Zeus, Pater, Father Zeus. And... If you think of the name of the king of the gods in Rome, Jupiter, it's clearly the same name. And in Sanskrit, I gather, it's Diospata. So it's a kind of emblematic illustration of the way in which those three ancient languages clearly had a common root. And today, the consensus among scholars would be that Zeus originated actually in what is now Ukraine as the sky god of a people that philologists call Indo-Europeans. and that already by the time that Homer and Hesiod are sitting down to write about Zeus, he's maybe two, three millennia old.
所以宙斯的完整名字是 Zeus Pater，即父神宙斯。而且……如果你想想罗马众神之王的名字 Jupiter（朱庇特），这显然是同一个名字。据我所了解，在梵语中它是 Diospata。所以这是一种标志性的说明，表明那三种古代语言显然有着共同的根源。而今天，学者们的共识是，宙斯实际上起源于现在的乌克兰，是语言学家所称的“印欧人”的天空之神。而且早在荷马和赫西奥德坐下来开始书写关于宙斯的故事时，他可能就已经有两三千年的历史了。
Tom, can I ask a layman's question? Actually, you might not be able to answer this. How can people possibly know where Zuse came from? How have they been able to trace that back to Ukraine? It's a very complicated question, and I think would require an entire episode, and it would be fun to do that episode. It involved a lot of linguistics. Right.
汤姆，我能问一个外行的问题吗？实际上，你可能回答不了这个问题。人们怎么可能知道宙斯是从哪里来的？他们怎么能把它追溯到乌克兰呢？这是一个非常复杂的问题，我想这需要整整一期节目来解答，而且做这样一期节目会很有趣。这涉及大量的语言学知识。对的。
People thought maybe that the Indo-Europeans came from Anatolia or further towards India. It's based on philological and archaeological evidence. And maybe we could do an episode on that because it is very, very interesting. That's a very good answer because it's someone saying, it's just satisfying, but also evasive. It's not evasive, but if we're going to get on with this, I haven't got time to get into how people have identified the homeland of the Indo-European. I know you know it, but you just don't want to waste time telling me. Go on, continue with your story. Exactly so.
人们曾认为印欧人可能来自安纳托利亚或更靠近印度的地方。这是基于语文学和考古学证据得出的。也许我们可以就此做一期节目，因为这真的非常、非常有趣。这是一个非常好的回答，因为这听起来既令人满足，又有些闪烁其词。这并不是闪烁其词，但如果我们想继续推进节目，我没有时间去深入探讨人们是如何确定印欧人发源地的。我知道你懂，但你只是不想浪费时间告诉我。得了吧，继续你的故事。正是如此。
But I think you can assume that the Greeks are Indo-European speakers, that they are coming into Greece from the north, and that therefore this is why the Greeks everywhere acknowledge Zeus as the king of the gods, because their ancestors have been doing so long before they ever came to Greece and came to identify themselves as distinct communities of Greeks. So that's something that all the Greeks shared long before they became Greek, if you see what I mean. And the Greekness, so when we think of the Greekness, you're thinking of, you know, the Greek islands, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, you know, stereotypical images of Greece. And yet, Greekness is slightly more, it's a more slippery and a more nuanced kind of concept in this period, isn't it? Because even the Greek myth, the Greekist of stories, have the stamp of other cultures, don't they? And that reflects the background of the two poets who are writing them, who are both. Yeah. I guess on the, would you say they're on the periphery of the Greek world?
但我想你可以假设希腊人是印欧语系的使用者，他们是从北方进入希腊的，因此这就是为什么全希腊到处都承认宙斯是众神之王，因为他们的祖先在来到希腊并把自己识别为不同的希腊人社群之前很久就已经这样做了。所以这是所有希腊人在成为希腊人之前很久就共同拥有的东西，如果你懂我的意思的话。而希腊性——所以当我们想到希腊性时，你会想到，你知道的，希腊诸岛，啦啦啦啦啦啦，你知道的，对希腊的刻板印象。然而，希腊性在这个时期是一个稍微更复杂、更难以捉摸、更微妙的概念，不是吗？因为即使是希腊神话中最具希腊特色的故事，也带有其他文化的烙印，对吧？这反映了书写它们的两位诗人的背景，他们俩都……是的。我想在……你会说他们处于希腊世界的边缘吗？
Is that, is that right? Yeah, so Homer is said to have lived on the island of Chios, which is just off the coast of Anatolia. And he said, as we heard, he's the son of a man who had moved from Anatolia to Greece. And it is, I would say, the consensus now among scholars that this does much to explain elements in their poetry that seems to derive ultimately not from this kind of inchoate Indo-European tradition, but from the great civilizations of Babylon, of Babylonia. of Mesopotamia. So one of these is the succession of one generation of gods by another, and to quote Martin West, complete with stories of crude and bizarre acts of violence of gods castrating, swallowing and generally clobbering each other. This is a kind of Babylonian notion that the Greek poets seem to have kind of absorbed. The division of
是这样吗？是的，据说荷马住在希俄斯岛上，该岛就位于安纳托利亚海岸附近。正如我们所听到的，据说他是从安纳托利亚搬到希腊的一个男人的儿子。而且，正如学者们现在的共识，这在很大程度上解释了他们诗歌中的某些元素——这些元素似乎最终并非源自这种杂乱无章的印欧传统，而是源自巴比伦、巴比伦尼亚以及美索不达米亚的伟大文明。其中之一就是代代神明的更迭，用马丁·韦斯特的话说，其中充满了粗俗和离奇的暴力行径的故事：神明们互相阉割、吞食并大打出手。这是一种巴比伦式的概念，希腊诗人似乎吸收了这种概念。将
the seas, the underworld and the sky between three gods, that's also very much a kind of Babylonian tradition and also the idea that the preeminent gods of a pantheon are 12 in number. So these are all very foundational notions that the Greeks have of their pantheon. And yet they do seem to have come from Babylonia. Right. And it reflects, I think, a particular moment in Greek history where they're recovering from the collapse that people have always called the dark ages in the wake of the Trojan War. And what we would recognize today is the beginnings of classical civilization, archaic Greek civilization is emerging. And they are open to influences from the broader world, of which these traditions that are coming from the Babylonians would be one, but also, of course, the alphabet
海洋、冥界和天空在三位神明之间进行瓜分，这也非常带有巴比伦传统的色彩，还有神话体系中的核心神明数量为12位的想法。所以这些都是希腊人对其神话体系所抱有的非常基础的概念。然而它们似乎确实来自巴比伦。没错。我认为这反映了希腊历史上一个特定的时刻：他们正在从人们一直称为特洛伊战争之后的“黑暗时代”的崩溃中恢复过来。而我们今天所认识的古典文明的萌芽、古风时期的希腊文明正在崛起。他们对来自更广阔世界的文化影响持开放态度，其中来自巴比伦的这些传统是一个方面，当然，来自腓尼基人的字母表则是另一个方面。
coming from the Phoenicians would be another. Yeah, of course. And is it not the case to push that even further, that a couple of the most famous, most celebrated Greek stories of all time, one of which is the Trojan War, that these are influenced by Babylonian traditions as well and are less Greek than we might imagine. I think not the story of the Trojan War itself. That's a whole like the option of the Europeans. That's another massive question whether the Trojan War was historical. But the sense of the Trojan War as having been deliberately stirred up by the gods, that does ultimately seem again to come from Mesopotamia. The claim that that Hesiod gives is that Zeus deliberately encourages the Trojan War, and also another war
是的，当然。为了更进一步地探讨，难道不是这样吗？有几个最著名、最受赞誉的希腊历史故事——其中之一就是特洛伊战争——其实也受到了巴比伦传统的影响，而且没有我们想象的那么具有希腊特色？我认为特洛伊战争的故事本身并非如此。那完全就像欧洲人的选择一样。特洛伊战争是否具有历史真实性是另一个巨大的问题。但特洛伊战争是由众神故意挑起的这种感觉，最终似乎又源自美索不达米亚。赫西奥德给出的说法是，宙斯故意煽动了特洛伊战争，还有在那之前几代人发生的另一场战争，
that had happened a couple of generations before that, which is war before seven gated Thebes as rivals fought over the flocks of Oedipus. So Thebes, of course, is in Beosha, where he'd lived, and we will be coming to this war and who Oedipus was in our next episode. But you have the Theban War and the Trojan War, and this does seem to come from. this Babylonian tradition that you'd had different ages of humanity, that the gods target these kind of different generations of humans for extermination. And again, it seems to be a kind of an orientalizing influence, as scholars have put it. But there is something that is distinctively Greek about these stories. And that is the notion that what Zeus is doing when he fosters the
也就是七门底比斯之战，当时敌对双方为了俄狄浦斯的羊群而战。所以底比斯当然在维奥蒂亚，也就是他曾经生活过的地方，我们将在下一集节目中讨论这场战争以及俄狄浦斯是谁。但是你有了底比斯战争和特洛伊战争，这似乎确实源于这种巴比伦传统，即人类存在不同的时代，而众神将这些不同代际的人类作为消灭的目标。正如学者们所说，这再次似乎是一种东方化的影响。但这些故事中确实有一些独特希腊化的东西。那就是这样一种观念：宙斯在挑起
Theban War and then the Trojan War is to wipe out a specific class of human being. And that is namely heroes. And the notion of heroes is something that seems distinctively Greek. It's not part of the ancestral Indo-European tradition. It doesn't seem to come from Babylonia. This perhaps, you know, who or what the heroes are, perhaps this is the key to explaining wise use is the kind of God that he is. Because the definition of a hero effectively is that they are men who were fathered by or descended from immortals and specifically and particularly Zeus and that they are therefore midway between mortals and immortals. They are founders of cities. They are fighters of monsters. And Hesiod's take is that Zeus, by populating the world with heroes,
底比斯战争和随后的特洛伊战争时，他所做的事情是消灭特定的一类人。那就是英雄。而英雄的概念是一个非常具有希腊特色的东西。它不是祖传印欧传统的一部分，似乎也不是来自巴比伦。也许（你知道的）英雄是谁或是什么，这也许就是解释为什么宙斯是那种特定性格的神明的关键。因为英雄的定义实际上是：他们是由不朽者生下或繁衍的凡人，特别且尤其是宙斯，因此他们介于凡人和不朽者之间。他们是城市的建立者，是怪物的斩杀者。而赫西奥德的看法是，宙斯通过用英雄充实世界，
by descending from Olympus and fathering these heroes on mortal women, had achieved a kind of cosmic order, a kind of balance in the way of things. But he couldn't allow it to last for too long. for reasons that are never entirely explained. And this is why he then decides to launch the Theban and Trojan wars. So let's dig into this a little bit, Tom. Where does this come from? Why would people come up with the idea of heroes? Does it express something distinctive about Greek civilization, do you think?
通过从奥林匹斯山降临并与凡间女性孕育这些英雄，实现了一种宇宙秩序，一种事物运行方式上的平衡。但他不能让这种状态持续太久，其原因从未被完全解释清楚。这就是为什么他后来决定发动底比斯战争和特洛伊战争。让我们深入探讨一下这个问题，汤姆。这究竟是从何而来的？为什么人们会想出英雄的概念？你认为这表达了希腊文明什么独特之处吗？
I think it does, and I think it expresses the sheer variety and number of independent cities that you have in the Greek world. They're all part of the Greek world, but they're all distinctive and independent. All these cities essentially, you know, they share in the worship of Zeus. and so they want to claim a kind of particular intimacy with him. And the obvious way to do this is to associate themselves with heroes who had been directly fathered by Zeus. And this, I think, is what explains the endless catalogue of rapes that are attributed to Zeus.
我认为是的，我认为它表达了希腊世界中独立城市纯粹的品种繁多和数量众多。它们都是希腊世界的一部分，但它们又都各具特色且独立。所有这些城市基本上，你知道的，都共同崇拜宙斯。因此它们都想宣称与他有一种特殊亲密的联系。而做到这一点的显而易见的方法，就是将自己与那些由宙斯直接孕育的英雄联系起来。我想，这就是为什么宙斯被归咎于无数次强奸的原因。
So you could look at, say, mainland Zeus, countries in the north, cities in the middle of Greece, cities in the south, they all have these stories. So in the north, you have the Macedonians, the people that Alexander the Great will come from. They claimed a line of descent from a hero called Macedon, whose father was Zeus. The citizens of Megara in the middle of Greece, just ran from Athens. They claim descent from a son of Zeus called Megaros. The Arcadians in the Peloponnese, the kind of the southern bit of Greece, they claim descent from a son of Zeus called Arcas. And even the name of Greece, the Greeks didn't call themselves Greeks.
所以你可以看看，比如希腊大陆的宙斯，北方的国家，希腊中部的城市，南方的城市，它们都有这些故事。所以在北方，你有马其顿人，亚历山大大帝就出身于此。他们声称自己是一名叫马其顿的英雄的后代，这位英雄的父亲是宙斯。希腊中部、紧邻雅典的墨加拉市民，他们声称自己是宙斯一个名叫墨加罗斯的儿子的后代。伯罗奔尼撒半岛的阿卡迪亚人（希腊南部的那个区域），他们声称自己是宙斯一个名叫阿尔卡斯的儿子的后代。甚至连“希腊”这个名字——希腊人其实并不称呼
themselves Helens. They lived in a land called Hellas. But we called Greeks because there was a guy called Grycos, who lived in a Pyros, kind of what's now northern Greece and Albania. And Grycos had been the father of these people called the Grykoi and the Romans picked up on this and that's why we called the Greeks, Greeks. But I mean, who remembers Grycos? I mean, he's a completely anonymous hero. So really what the point of heroes is they're reflecting the fragmentation of the Greek political landscape and the fact there are so many competing cities and they're They each needs a father figure, but they don't want to claim a god, because the gods are universal, so they basically invent a tear down that will give them legitimacy.
自己为希腊人，他们称自己为海伦人。他们生活在一片名为海拉斯的土地上。但我们被称为希腊人，是因为曾有一个名叫格赖科斯的家伙，他住在伊庇鲁斯（大致相当于现在的希腊北部和阿尔巴尼亚）。格赖科斯是这些被称为“格赖科伊”的人的祖先，罗马人注意到了这一点，这就是为什么我们被称为希腊人（Greeks）。但话说回来，谁还记得格赖科斯呢？我的意思是，他是一个完全默默无闻的英雄。所以实际上，英雄的意义在于，它们反映了希腊政治格局的分裂，以及存在着如此多互相竞争的城市这一事实，它们每个都需要一个父亲形象，但它们又不想认一个神作为父亲，因为神是普世的，所以它们基本上发明了一个介于中间的等级来赋予自己合法性。
Yeah, and I think Zeus specifically is universal. Right. So Athena, for instance, is obviously the patrons specifically of Athens, and there are other cities that claim various Olympians as their particular patron, but Zeus is for the entire Greek world. So I think that's one explanation for who the heroes are. I think also they reflect traditions that are really. really very ancient. And these traditions tend to be focused on the northern Peloponnese around
是的，而且我认为宙斯具有独特的普世性。没错。比如，雅典娜显然是雅典专属的保护神，还有其他城市宣称某些奥林匹斯神是他们特别的保护神，但宙斯是属于整个希腊世界的。所以我想这是对英雄是谁的一种解释。我认为他们也反映了那些真的非常、非常古老的传统。而这些传统往往集中在北部伯罗奔尼撒半岛的
Argos, around Mycini. So heroes who associated with those cities seem to be drawing on kind of really venerable traditions. And these are the heroes who are kind of universally popular, universally known. Right. Poets write about them. They appear on pots or whatever. And the obvious examples of these are the heroes of Homer. So Agamemnon and Menelaus. Agamemnon is the king of Mycini. Menelaus is the king of Sparta. But you also have heroes from that region who go back several generations before the Trojan War. And these figures are some of the most famous of all Greek heroes. They are monster slayers because they live in an age when the world is teeming with monsters. And the
阿哥斯和迈锡尼周围。因此，与这些城市相关的英雄似乎汲取了真正古老的传统。这些英雄是那种普遍受欢迎、人尽皆知的英雄。没错。诗人们写他们，他们出现在陶器上等等。最明显的例子就是荷马史诗中的英雄。比如阿伽门农和墨涅拉俄斯。阿伽门农是迈锡尼国王，墨涅拉俄斯是斯巴达国王。但你也有来自该地区的英雄，他们可以追溯到特洛伊战争之前的几代人。这些人物是所有希腊英雄中最著名的几位。他们是斩杀怪物的英雄，因为他们生活在一个世界上怪物滋生的时代。而其中
two most formidable of these are both sons of Zeus. So the first is Perseus, who comes to rule as the king of Argos, and then there is his great-grandson, the strongest man who ever lived, and this is Heracles. Anybody who's read the green myths as a child or even who hasn't will be aware of these two currenters. So Perseus, my son's favorite Greek hero, by the way. Mine as well. I always liked Perseus. Really? Yeah, he loved Perseus. So he killed Medusa the Gorgon famously. She was a, you know, had terrible hair. Well, not originally though. Really? She had beautiful hair and then it gets turned into kind of coiling, hissing snakes. Yeah, of course. It's kind of punishment, isn't it? And then she turns people to stone because she's so
最强大的两个都是宙斯的儿子。第一个是珀尔修斯，他后来成为了阿哥斯国王；然后是他的曾孙、有史以来最强壮的人，也就是赫拉克勒斯。任何小时候读过希腊神话、甚至没读过的人都会知道这两个人物。顺便说一句，珀尔修斯是我儿子最喜欢的希腊英雄。我也是。我一直很喜欢珀尔修斯。真的吗？是的，他很喜欢珀尔修斯。所以他最有名的功绩是杀死了蛇发女怪美杜莎。她是一个，你知道的，头发很可怕的人。不过最初不是这样的，对吧？真的吗？她原本有一头漂亮的头发，后来被变成了那种盘绕、嘶嘶作响的蛇。是的，当然。这算是一种惩罚，不是吗？然后她因为太
ugly. Well, originally she was ugly. But by the 5th century, that story has slightly changed. So she's described as fair-cheeked Medusa. And there's this idea that she's simultaneously terribly beautiful and terribly ugly and it's the horror of her hair that offsets the beauty of her face and Perseus famously he gets help by Athena he gets help by Hermes
丑而把人变成石头。嗯，她最初其实并不丑。但到了公元前5世纪，这个故事稍微发生了一些变化。所以她被描述为“脸颊白皙的美杜莎”。这里有一种观点认为，她同时具有可怕的美丽和可怕的丑陋，正是她那可怕的头发衬托出了她脸庞的美丽。而珀尔修斯最著名的经历是，在雅典娜的帮助下，在赫尔墨斯的帮助下——
who gives him his wing sandals he goes off he cuts off the head of Medusa by looking into a mirror as he does so he then gets the head puts it in a sack goes off he rescues Andromeda a princess from a sea monster
赫尔墨斯给了他长着翅膀的凉鞋，他出发了，通过看着一面镜子斩下了美杜莎的头颅，然后他把头颅放进一个袋子里出发去拯救被海怪袭击的公主安德烈玛达，
turns a sea monster into stone ends up king of Argos and gives the Medusa's head to Athena who puts it on her shield to strike terror into all that she fights. So he's a famous hero, but he's not as famous as Heracles, who is the greatest of all monster killers. And Heracles, for complicated reasons, that we won't go into, although it would be great to do an episode on Heracles at some point. But he has to do these 12 labours, and a lot of these labours involve the killing of monsters. So there's the Nemean lion which have been raised by by hera has an invulnerable hide
把海怪变成石头，最终成为了阿哥斯国王，并把美杜莎的头送给了雅典娜，雅典娜把它挂在自己的盾牌上，用来震慑她在战斗中的所有敌人。所以他是一位著名的英雄，但他没有赫拉克勒斯那么有名，赫拉克勒斯是所有怪物杀手中最伟大的一位。由于一些我们不会深入探讨的复杂原因——尽管以后能做一期关于赫拉克勒斯的节目会很棒——赫拉克勒斯必须完成这12项伟大的功绩，而其中的许多功绩都涉及到杀死怪物。首先是涅墨亚狮子，它是由
you know can't be cut by arrows or swords or whatever so Heracles throttles it and then skins it using its own claws and he from that point on wears it as a kind of armour so you can always recognise Heracles because he has the skin of a lion draped over his head and his shoulders and then there's the Hydra one of our favourite metaphors on the rest of history every time you cut a head off another one grows
赫拉养大的，拥有一层刀枪不入的皮毛，
back, and so Heracles defeats it by taking us a blazing torch and searing the flesh. There's the Ehromanthian boar, which he captures in a snowdrift. There's the Stimphalian birds, which have terrible metal feathers, kind of bronze beaks, devour men. And Heracles defeats them. He gets a rattle, and the noise of the rattle scares the snifalian birds off, and then he shoots them with his arrows. There's a cretan bull, which is the father of the minor tour. There's the mares of Diomedes, which again eat flesh like the Stimphalian birds.
箭和剑都无法划破它，所以赫拉克勒斯用双手勒死了它，然后用它自己的爪子剥下狮皮。从那时起，他一直把它当成一种盔甲穿着，所以你总是能认出赫拉克勒斯，因为他的头上和肩膀上披着一张狮子皮。然后是许德拉（九头蛇），这是我们最喜欢的《历史余音》隐喻之一：每次你砍掉一个头，就会长出另一个，
There's Gerion, who has cattle in the far west. We talked about him in the episode on Hannibal, how Heracles steals the cattle from Gerion and drives them back through Spain and Gaul and down through Italy. And then there's Cerberus, who like Gerion, conventionally is portrayed with three heads. He's the dog that guards the entrance to the underworld and has snakes. for his tail. But according to Hesiod, he actually had 50 heads. So again, there's kind of all kinds of potential there for elaboration. So obviously Perseus and Heracles have a lot in common. They're fulfilling similar roles to some degree, aren't they? And one of the things they really
所以赫拉克勒斯拿起一把燃烧的火炬烧灼伤口，从而击败了它。还有厄律曼托斯野猪，他在雪堆中捕获了它。还有斯廷法洛斯湖怪鸟，它们有着可怕的金属羽毛、青铜般的喙，会吞噬人类。赫拉克勒斯击败了它们。他拿了一个拨浪鼓，拨浪鼓的声音吓跑了斯廷法洛斯湖怪鸟，然后他用箭射杀它们。还有克里特公牛，它是米诺陶洛斯的父亲。还有狄俄墨德斯的母马，它们和斯廷法洛斯湖怪鸟一样吃人肉。
have in common is they're both the children of Zeus. So in both cases, you've got Zeus and you've got a mortal mother. And Zeus has come to the mother in both cases disguised. So he visited Percy's his mother, Danai, disguised implausibly, I think, as a shower of gold. Oh, you think that's implausible? Yeah. And his car, Heracles's mother, alchemone, disguised as her husband, Amphitrion, because Amphitron is off at the battlefield and Zeus is dressed up as him and whatever. Now, what's going on there? What's all that about?
还有革律翁，他在远西方拥有牛群。我们在关于汉尼拔的那集节目中讨论过他，赫拉克勒斯如何从革律翁那里偷走牛群，把它们赶过西班牙、高卢并穿过意大利。还有刻耳柏洛斯，和革律翁一样，传统上被描绘成三个头。它是看守冥界入口的狗，尾巴是
Well, by fathering these two heroes, Zeus is helping to cleanse the world of monsters. A lot of the monsters we've described emerged from a kind of context that reaches back to a period before the Olympians. So there's a sense that Zeus is cleaning up the neighborhood by fathering these heroes. Okay. With Heracles, particularly, he doesn't just cleanse the world of monsters. He also, he will end up coming to the rescue of the gods. There's a prophecy that the giants who were born when Uranus' is. testicles were flung across the world and the blood and seamen splashed and the giants grew up.
蛇。但根据赫西奥德的说法，它实际上有50个头。所以同样，这里有很多可以进行加工和艺术加工的空间。显然，珀尔修斯和赫拉克勒斯有很多共同点。他们在某种程度上承担着相似的角色，不是吗？他们确实有一个共同点，那就是他们都是宙斯的儿子。所以在这两种情况下，你都有宙斯和一个凡人母亲。而且在这两种情况下，宙斯都是伪装后去见母亲的。他拜访珀尔修斯的母亲达娜厄时，伪装成了一阵金雨，我觉得这太难以置信了。哦，你觉得这难以置信？是的。而赫拉克勒斯的母亲阿尔克墨涅，则伪装成她的丈夫安菲特律翁，因为安菲特律翁当时在前线打仗，宙斯打扮成他的样子等等。那么，这到底是怎么回事？这究竟是搞什么名堂？
They have not gone from the scene. They're lurking around. And it's been foretold that they will attack Olympus and that only Heracles will be able to save the gods from defeat. And so that's another reason the Greeks come to explain why Zeus had fathered Heracles on Alkmeni. Even Heera, who had particularly persecuted Heracles. Heracles. She was particularly resentful of the fact that he was Zeus's son by another woman. She ends up being reconciled with Heracles in the end because Heracles uniquely among mortal heroes ends up becoming a god himself. His mortal body is consumed by a pyre, flames burn away the flesh, but he ascends in a chariot up to Olympus where he is welcomed by Heera, who gives him Hebe, her daughter, by Zeus to be Heracles' wife. The literal meaning of Heracles is the glory of Heera. So I guess you could say that, you know, Zeus is doing what has to be done to defend his throne.
好吧，通过孕育这两位英雄，宙斯在帮助净化世界的怪物。我们所描述的许多怪物都源于一种可以追溯到奥林匹斯神之前时期的背景。所以有一种感觉，宙斯通过孕育这些英雄来清理这个社区。好的。特别是对于赫拉克勒斯而言，他不仅清除了世界上的怪物。他最终还将前往拯救诸神。有一个预言说，当乌拉诺斯的睾丸被抛向世界各地、鲜血和精液四溅时诞生的那些巨人，
And there's no sense, do you think, among the Greeks, that Zeus has behaved badly in disguising himself and sleeping with these women? Well, this becomes the huge question for some of the greatest poets who write in the classical period, the golden age of Greece in the 5th century, that in the classical period, the 5th century BC, will be explored by some of the most celebrated poets and writers in Athens. And the question essentially is, can the cruelty of the gods and a sense of them being just, is it possible to reconcile them? And, you know, this question undoubtedly evolves from the age of Hesiod, up to the age of
他们并没有从世间消失。他们潜伏在四周。并且有预言称他们将袭击奥林匹斯山，只有赫拉克勒斯才能拯救众神免于失败。所以这也是希腊人用来解释为什么宙斯要与阿尔克墨涅孕育赫拉克勒斯的另一个原因。甚至连一直特别迫害赫拉克勒斯的赫拉——赫拉克勒斯。她对他是宙斯与其他女性所生的儿子这一事实格外愤恨。最终她还是与赫拉克勒斯和解了，因为赫拉克勒斯在凡人英雄中独一无二地最终成了一位神明。他的凡躯在火葬柴堆中被燃尽，火焰烧掉了他的血肉，但他乘着战车升上奥林匹斯山，在那里受到了赫拉的欢迎，赫拉将她与宙斯的女儿赫柏嫁给赫拉克勒斯做妻子。“赫拉克勒斯”这个名字的字面意思就是“赫拉的荣耀”。所以我想你可以说，宙斯在做他为了捍卫王座必须做的事。
the golden age of Athens in the 5th century BC. And so that's why, Dominic, I think in our next episode, that's what we should focus on. Yes, what a great idea. In that episode, we will be travelling to the city of Thebes, which was the home of King Edipus, and a family that even by the standards of Greek myth was quite safe. sensationally dysfunctional. So people will be able to hear that episode on Thursday. But actually, do you know what?
你认为希腊人中难道没有人觉得宙斯在伪装自己并与这些女性睡觉的行为表现得很糟糕吗？好吧，这成了生活在古典时期（希腊公元前5世纪的黄金时代）最伟大的一些诗人们面临的巨大问题：在公元前5世纪的古典时期，这个问题将由雅典最受赞誉的诗人和作家们进行探讨。本质上的问题是：诸神的残酷与他们内心的正义感，这两者有可能调和吗？而且，毫无疑问，这个问题从赫西奥德的时代一直演变到了公元前5世纪雅典的黄金时代。所以这就是为什么，多米尼克，我认为在我们的下一集节目中，这应该是我们关注的重点。
If you can't wait, if you absolutely can't wait, the way to hear it is to ascend to our very own Mount Olympus, to join our beloved pantheon, our chat community, and to join the ranks of the immortals at the rest is history.com. Because not only do you get eternal life and all of that and you get Thunderbolts, but you get a whole range of benefits, don't you, Tom? You absolutely do. It's literally like becoming an immortal.
是的，真是个好主意。在那一集中，我们将前往底比斯城，那是俄狄浦斯王的故乡，这个家族即使以希腊神话的标准来看，也处于一种令人发指的不正常状态。所以大家可以在周四收听那一集节目。但事实上，你知道吗？
Better, actually. It's better. It's like listening to the rest of history and it never, ever ends. Imagine that. Imagine that. The Elysian feels. Yeah. All right.
如果你等不及了，如果你真的等不及了，收听它的方法就是登上我们自己的奥林匹斯山，加入我们深爱的万神殿、我们的聊天社区，加入《历史余音》的不朽者行列。因为你不仅能获得永生和所有这些福利，还能得到雷霆霹雳，而且你还能获得全方位的特权，对吧，汤姆？你绝对会的。这简直就像成了永生者一样。
Brilliant. So on that bombshell, Talemi Agoutara. Goodbye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
其实更好。这更好。这就像收听《历史余音》而且永远、永远不会结束。想象一下。想象一下。极乐净土。是的。好吧。太棒了。伴随着这个重磅消息，Tale mi agoutara（再见）。本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。